[Music]
hey there I'm Theo von and welcome to
allegedly now I'm not with my co-host
Matthew cold Weiss at the moment but uh
but he'll be here he's gonna be jumping
into this episode because this episode
is a special gift to you guys it's a
Happy New Year's
Taipa episode and we want to wish you a
Happy New Year by revisiting moments the
best of moments from this previous year
actually year and a quarter since our
podcast has been in existence for that
long we're gonna go that full year and a
quarter and we're gonna draw the best
moments out and we're gonna pop in and
out of them you're gonna love it there's
some of our absolute favorites some of
your favorites so we hope you love it we
love you guys we appreciate the support
and this is going to be the best of
allegedly from 2016 and a little bit of
2015 so thank you so much we love you
and now let's get to the episode on
behalf of myself and Matthew Cole Weiss
this is the best stove with guests David
Faustino talking about George Harrison
and Christina Applegate but I was in New
York once and but this would this goes
against the story because it was a guy
talking about Christina but I'm walking
through New York everybody's just shot
when you're when you're famous in New
York it's the most is the best
experience because everyone's just
yelling [ __ ] so I remember this guy's
walking past me and it's black dude he's
walking past me and he's like hey bud I
said well he goes oh man
Christina Applegate your sister man I
want to tap that you telling you you
could tell he was gonna say you tell her
I want to [ __ ] her you tell her I want
any pause you told I wanna did you relay
the message well no the message I did
relay to her is win
the beetle okay I can't believe I can't
remember Jason told me that he would
have liked to eat her [ __ ] Wow and to
tell her that she's probably never met a
[ __ ] licking beetle before and that's is
that a true story
absolute true story yes yes he was a
giant Mary with children fan which is
which was yeah to find that out you know
what I mean to like meet George Harrison
and be like nervous as [ __ ] and then to
find out like he's this giant fan of
Mary with children was just surreal you
know and that he's a [ __ ] licking and
that easy toe click whatever it'll you
tell her I'm you know that I want to eat
her [ __ ] and I said when I when I left
I just made another like alluded it to
it I alluded to it again saying I'm
gonna let her know he goes yeah yeah
yeah you let her know I bet she's never
met a [ __ ] licking beetle before Wow
so I literally because I didn't have
work the very next day so I went in and
I sat we were all sitting on the little
bundy couch on the set and i told the
whole cast the story that morning they
were just like you know just like
they're just cracking up Wow actually
quiet shy Beatle Wow with Jamie Kennedy
talking about Fran Drescher tell me
about a cougar that's hit on you at some
point I mean there's gotta be a sweet
coogan talent that [ __ ] rang up the
JK like a famous yeah there's got to be
one
oh yes I have a story but I don't wanna
get in trouble okay so all right so who
couldn't get it I know right she should
laugh at this so she seems she remembers
she won't even hear this podcast just
cut to so um I'm starting to do well you
know I'm doing really well and at one
time I was starring in a movie it was
done and I was producing three shows so
for the WB and so I was producing a show
called
living with Fran and based on my
experiences coming up with a community
and Dave Garrett and the woman had these
two sons that were older than us and she
was having sex with him and I lived in
the closet Matt
and I literally lit and saw this woman
in Westwood like lettuce lived there
with struggling comedians and he was
like art he was going to law school and
he did all our deals I'm like not
literally like we would go with Tomi
Rome is like alright you catch two
plates of ribs chill dude twenty minutes
pay some gas like that was like our
early lawyer right
Wow and so long story short is we do we
hire Fran Drescher
and you know she's a powerhouse you know
and so I'm trying to think of the so
she's hired as an actress and eventually
you know she brings in her writer Frank
I got it I'm trying to enact yeah baby
Frank so she brings Frank who's like
written London and all the stuff in
Frank's a great guy so then we go and
then like as we're doing that she's
hired as an actress and then like I hear
that like Fran now she wants something
in the writers room and then she and she
like took our little dressing room and
made it [ __ ] of velvet I'm not
kidding right all velvet like leopard
velvet like it's not a character this
layer and it was like really comfy and
she's really sweet
to this day I have a / Barry a Burberry
passport cover because of her so so
anyway she's like you know and so she
goes come out to me alibi she's a
greenhouse demon she says I want to talk
to CEO I'm trying to do the accent I
can't remember and she got and I said
okay so we go out the Malibu and it was
like before what Nobu was now is like
tucked away and we're just drinking and
[ __ ] I don't care right and then we
talking she because you know they shall
really need my input and I was like okay
and she goes it really could if I could
be like an executive producer and she's
like more you know more eel and I was
like a teal and like sake and I'm like
oh friend you know the deal is cuz I
know that it's gonna come out of
somebody's end yeah and no one is
[ __ ] giving up their in everyone's
like yo she's gonna eat you up for AP
credit it's out of your ass and I'm like
no I'm like okay and I'm like just I'm
like so then we eat and I'm pretty
toasted right so then we get her a car
and it's like oh if I can
they dope Mercedes I mean we drive and
she's like literally has a dope house on
PC agent like I can you pass it all the
time you just don't know it and it's
like sneaky it's like one little door
but and it just goes down it's like just
like Europe it's dope right
and um and she's like you know you
really like that [ __ ] and I was like
I was like being a high but you're not
drunk she's like yeah my name is like
six dog she's like mr. whiskers come
here and it's like Leopard she opens up
her [ __ ] refrigerator and what's in
there am I kidding like it was my
hundred bottles a [ __ ] sock like she
known and I was like what the [ __ ] she
goes yeah honey I get it for free they
want me to do it and then add like like
but I felt like we were place it was the
same [ __ ] sake that Nobu had at this
[ __ ] place Wow I'm like so then what
do we do we open up another bottle the
side and so we're there and it's like I
had just you know I was doing all right
I was running through a few things and I
was like the last thing I wanted to do
at this time I was be tied down any
girlfriend yeah I was like you know and
so she think you know he pain I did it
honestly be honest I did it on other
things I'm good hey you can't see what
I'm doing right you guys you described
and she's thank you you know I know how
to do it like the [ __ ] like shawl
like she was in a shawl and then that
came off yeah and then shove it out and
then like but she's great but she's like
my you know like my Jewish hint and I'm
right and I'm not a Jew and you know but
I haven't but she's but she's you know
she's sexy yeah and um she's like bunny
and she's like as she's just like you
know I can really produce and as some
more she's talking about producing and
what the more I'm like hemming and
hawing he know this
top-heavy and there's four like another
piece of clothing came off and then and
then she owned the show and then like
literally there was like a moment this
is kind of like a man ending where it
was like can I say this
so she's sweet and I knew I couldn't not
[ __ ] yeah where I don't need ass she's a
star and I respect her and she's
hilarious and you know I hope she
doesn't hear this in this day and age no
one will ever hear this and she was
basically it was like it was like the
reverse thing of like the reverse
casting couch and um then I was like
looking or like can I do this am I gonna
do this at my apartment and you were
wasted I was sued I was deep sake yeah
and I was like oh and and and and I just
this and I just said I can't I can't and
I didn't do it she's like what do you
mean what's going on and I don't know I
just couldn't do it and it would you
regret it to this day
no like she was always been nice to me
and I thought this would be an
interesting story did she get an AP
credit she ended up somehow again she
wanted to if it didn't work with you it
might have worked with me but she's
probably gonna hate me now but um look
it was top-heavy she won and I just
remember I was like if I do this then
I'm gonna you know I was the victim
because then I thought I do that yo you
[ __ ] right now my question that's early
feminism - oh boy there was a time
period you started with a hot chick a
hot woman oh yeah I'm so recently and I
honestly would have at least probably
felt myself in her in my car to her Wow
well that that's what a compliment
man last night I watched socially
unacceptable with Joey Diaz I don't know
if you've seen it or not it's a
hilarious new comedy special it's
the best Joey's a real comedian guys
he's no jokes no frills
I mean jokes but I mean he's like a real
he's a human being you know you get to
know him you're not just hearing some
riddles and I saw it on C so if you've
been s ee s o dot-com it's the new ad
free streaming service bringing you
hilarious original series weeks of
stand-up specials as much Santa peace
you could want from comedians you've
heard of and something you haven't you
want to learn a new artist you tired of
the same old artists will then make a
change and check out some new ones as
bendable comedy anytime anywhere it has
every episode of SNL ever including the
new episodes the day after they air so
you didn't see it last night it's Sunday
you wondering what happened on SNL
everybody's done check it out right
there it also has the Tonight Show with
Jimmy Fallon and Late Night with Seth
Meyers the day after they air so you can
see the full episodes they even have
classics like 30 rock Parks and Rec and
Saved by the Bell when you know a little
better now make it on time they even
have British comedies I don't like the
British so those aren't for me but they
might be for you they do have the
original office the office with Ricky
Gervais see never seen that season
that's the one that spurned the great
American series you want to check it out
man you'll want to check it out
they have bajillion dollar properties
from the mines of Reno number one and
comedy bang bang
but jillion dollar properties it's a
it's basically like a play on like those
million dollar property shows so if you
and your wife or you or your animal
loves those shows you'll love it there
on seeso se ESO calm and right now our
allegedly listeners can try see so free
for two months when they use promo code
Theo
at checkout that's right promo code Theo
th EO at checkout just go to see so calm
right now to sign up for two three
months with promo code Theo
at checkout
that's C SOCOM promo code Theo you're
gonna love it
you're gonna absolutely love it hours of
Santos specials it's ad free you get a
month two months free from us and it's
only 399 after that four bucks you got a
whole new amazing channel filled with
content that you're gonna love all right
now let's get back to the best of with
guest
Zachery ty brian talking about wanting
to hook up with his TV mom
hubba-hubba okay so bro like obviously
you know so I mean I grew up watching
home improvement you know and it's I
mean it's just been an icon staple and
so many people's existence did patricia
richardson was she kind of never milfy
to you at all were you ever like you had
to be going through puberty and she was
like this pretty lady
you know she absolutely was yeah cuz I
remember I had a huge crush on my
neighbor's mom and like I didn't know
how to I didn't know what a crush was
and next thing you know I just like
wanted to like be next to this lady with
my crotch so she was like Stifler's mom
before stephanie was it's funny she was
absolutely was I actually just met with
her last week last Friday
Jonathan club she's running for SAG
after president Oh ballot sacks I'm
gonna make sure to vote for yeah she's
great she's part of the MF party and
they're they're really you say am i LF
according to me that's a witty I'm gonna
vote for ya but she's so anyways I
actually was tested we were sitting down
we were just you know shooting the [ __ ]
talking about she was talking about
running and you know she wanted me to
endorse her and whatnot and and I
actually just I got the balls to tell
her and I was like actually you know
back in the day cuz we're working on
this show right now Jonathan jtt and I
and and actually this so this would be
one of the episodes anyways yes it's so
ironic you asked that absolutely yeah
like more than Pamela and Debbie like
more than the tool girls I'm sure cuz
she was right there but and the more
motherly she was the hotter scenes
that's my I think this is very normal
for adolescent 100% yeah I've actually
like to explore this with a therapist
and just to get there I was gonna say
that's a little bit of mother issues a
little bit well when you put any kind of
sexuality on to someone who acts
motherly towards you then that's a
mother issue I'm not saying it's wrong
I'm just saying that as part of the yeah
this I'd like to actually talk to you
lately
cuz I mean my mother I don't think
anything bad because you were going
through that time in your life like you
went through puberty probably a lot of
those feelings aroused while you're on
this show i mean i can't i'm sure i
sometime pleasured myself to the idea of
her richardson well I can tell you I did
not I can I mean I never it never was
like recession or anything but it was
definitely you know how you always like
you said you always had like that
friends mom that was super cute or
whatever I had I did definitely thought
she was hot yeah in an odd way good
question that wasn't a very interesting
I've never been asked that well I
remember I used to go in my buddy's
mom's closet and her sweater
oh my god playing guess the STD with
guest dr. drew specific mini competition
is dr. drew here is going to give us
symptoms of a STD anyone I do whole
series you know do a couple and then
we'll see Theo and I have to guess what
it is I'll do a bunch of them okay okay
all right good you come in your
partner's got gonorrhea you haven't had
sex with her
she hasn't been cheating what do you
have come in your partner has gotten
come inside the partner are you coming
with me come with me and you're like I
know what's gonna she has gonorrhea and
we she and I have not been having
intercourse we've not been having
intercourse I promise me of course
doctors really other line they're like
way that's right assume well right
but you not it looks for fact any of
course you get around a little bit
yourself
and you have something so this guy has
so well okay I'll say yes you have
something okay what do you have the guy
has the clap where because she has the
clap she has gonorrhea gonorrhea is the
clap yeah wait chlamydia
know what clap is really gonorrhea class
oh no I don't know a guy has oral
gonorrhea yes has no symptoms oh so then
no you have it what about even bad
breath Wow come to me you you you were
this coming to doctors you hate going to
doctors these guys and you have a rash
on your palms it's a very strange rash
red blotchy rash on your palms and
you've noticed some the lymph nodes
swollen up on your arms right there and
but the rash is fading so you you almost
didn't make your appointment so it's not
is it it's not just friction from over
masturbation it's not it's on both hands
it's symmetric and it's a rash is a
right a little bit on your feet too
okay okay um both hands open your feet
and it's fading its fading and and maybe
maybe you've tried to remember and you
think maybe you had a sore on your penis
but it didn't didn't hurt or indecent
went away it's no big deal so I didn't
come in for that I love that you're
really playing the part I love it okay
um it's I'll keep going yeah you
discipline yes yes whereas Shanker was
Sankar is a painless ulcer that goes
away
most guys most people don't kids the
ulcer occurs that yours at the point of
contact
uh-huh goes away and then you get
secondary syphilis which is typically a
rash and the rest and there can be
gummys there could be other things that
kind of develop and then that goes away
and then a certain percentage of people
get something called tertiary syphilis
where it gets into your will spinal
fluid and eat your brain oh so if you
meet a real dumb chick you could have
that or dumb boy
so just one one Wow
do we have to be you guys are kind of
bring a woman in oh yeah bring a woman
oh yeah this is just comes in this is
knowledge by the way she's got a bad
yeast infection but her lymph nodes are
really Swan or grind they really hurt
and they bother and she feels kind of
tired and crappy and this this has been
a it's useful all the yeast Medicaid
doesn't seem to go away and just keeps
going burrowing it's bad oh oh I know
this one uh because I know someone who
has it I think they will it if she
waited long enough it would go away
right right this is um her boyfriend had
something like because this had a red
mark that he kind of said his penis
memories where the show has been you
know he don't really think anything of
it but he had the same thing on his
lymph nodes
hold on let me take some no I know this
I know it I know exactly what it is and
it's gonorrhea no [ __ ] I know it is cuz
it's not like life-threatening no equal
midia no it's uh what a classics HPV no
that's the usually you don't know you
have it because that normal paps can
cause warts but although people need to
get their vaccines for the HPV I've been
chatting about that for years and
finally people are coming around to that
so yes prevent cancer get your HPV
vaccine sponsor this is also a virus and
people are struggling to create a
vaccine against it and it's not rabies
huh it's herpes herpes and yeah yes I
was thinking of the mouth no that could
be on the mouth cause like there's been
celebrities who have the sores and stuff
on it and then anything all right
herpes alright tide so we need a
tiebreaker we need to get one do you
want me to go obscure or do you know
obscure obscure probably I don't think
we know obscure yeah I don't know much
about vaginas in general
okay this is a let's try this you won't
know these I live in a tropical area and
I've got this shaggy ulcer on my penis
and these huge lymph nodes developing
and this ulcer a not going away it is it
is
I can't wait doesn't really hurt but it
kind of does but it's [ __ ] it looks like
a giant clam on my penis it's nasty
lookin cow gangrene Zink right okay
[Music]
there's got to be one more that we don't
have there obscure stuff that happens I
like a little anal play mm-hmm put that
on a loop and I noticed these sort of
skin tags are around my anus there and
they they seem to get beginning more
anal warts this girl in Nebraska had
them that's associated with anal cancer
too so everybody gets really yes
Oh Margaret and then if you are
listening I didn't even tell her about
him but I saw him and you probably need
to get brushed up with guest Farrah
Abraham talking about dr. drew we had
dr. drew on this show he came in and he
I feel like he said some things like
about who strangling he's strangling
people violent I kind of not about that
anymore in my career so did that set you
yeah
just because I'm one of my other shows
Celebrity Big Brother literally it was
like a legal situation in people through
tears at me tried to beat the [ __ ] out
of me and thought it was pantomime and
they brought it up beforehand so I could
only imagine if I go into work with dr.
Drew and he strangles me then he said go
I talked about her earlier it was just
all pantomime and it's just kind of like
a real situation with me I know that
that's totally weird probably to here
but it actually happened to me and I
like boyars and they got detained they
couldn't go back into the country
because of this and then they lied so
that's just why I bring it up and I'm
gonna work with people like that anymore
have you spoken to him no I haven't he
has my number if you want to say hey he
can shout out but you wanted him off the
show I mean he doesn't have to be off
the show they can just bring in a
different host while I am on the show
getting interviewed about my real like
personal questions they can have someone
who can act like they give a [ __ ]
so with dr. drew having said what he
said do you trust dr. drew I don't trust
someone who jokes around and I think
there was something set of like fair
just wants attention or something like
yeah I think that is one's own opinion
and he was on the show like he was
further impressed like I'm furthering
press right now I'm going out right now
I have nothing to hide I you know I'm
getting ready for Teen Mom the next
season so if I choose to come on shows
if I choose to come on you guys the
podcast is probably for those reasons
right right um but I'm not here to talk
about strangling or but were you
personally it seemed like someone else
did press not me deflecting that when
I'm here I don't do that with guest mark
McGrath talking about his best moment
looking back at your days yeah in the
partying days and whatnot looking at the
positive side is there a story that pops
out to you like we tell stories or
something that you remember as I can't
believe this [ __ ] happen to me story
yeah like of something out of the rock
star life something that pops in your
head you know it's funny when people go
hey what's the craziest story I know
it's like I'm not gonna tell you cuz
it's gonna make people look a [ __ ]
jail you don't have said yeah yeah yeah
but you know I I have more my stories
like what great memories I had doing
that we're surreal yeah you know we open
for the Rolling Stones in 1999 okay
every morning was number one on the
charts okay and I'm singing every
morning and like the Rolling Stones
audiences are a little difficult
they're like Metallica audiences they're
not looking for a band to open and I
further her hero their lords yeah yeah
you know exactly and so it took us a
while to get him going and they're kind
of like let's these douche bags doing
open for the stones but we were breaking
him down we had a couple hits we had fly
you know we've hit him a fly and then we
didn't
every morning which is number one the
week opening stones and some doing song
winning over the audience I look over
and there's Mick and Keith watching and
just like bobbing their heads along like
that and I just go this is the most
surreal I don't think it's gonna get any
better than this right here it never did
I mean I was fully aware of it you know
and so that was an incredible moment
with Saturday Night Live's Cheri Oteri
you know I was a child and a little
scared yeah there's no reason that a
child should not mm-hmm you know see
know and exist with you know among right
well that could be said about a lot of
things that's why people don't like gay
people because they just don't know them
something else but I love that they're
Thiel's I love what TLC is doing with
their programming and introducing you
know I mean even like you look at the
Duggars you have to make sure you you
have to do it you bet your own
background check and you have to think
what do I want
you know what's gonna get out there what
make it out there but I just loved that
family so well no he's got to spread
with his new wife and People magazine
this week who the guy is it roll off
yeah yeah yeah he got married to a
full-size woman oh that's the son yes oh
yeah the son just to get the son of AI
episode I saw was the son was planning
his can look it up there's that that's
the one brother and Lucas is the brown
haired one the younger boy Mary
great Mary I think you're dmoz and and
then like the other twin brother how hot
is that guy he's like Italy yeah the
Roloff kids I mean oh they're sized and
ones oh really I live in they're twins
yeah I always thought the kids were
great I always thought something really
well-adjusted yeah and I think because
of their parents and they ran a pumpkin
farm man that's it I mean I gotta ask
are you someone who loves to
you know drive are you someone who just
plain loves people like you know a
people person are you planning an exotic
vacation for next summer and you need to
fund it are you seeking alternate
funding for your new startup or second
business well I've got an idea for you
it's a smart way to earn extra money and
get an extra $500 bonus
right now driving with lyft that's right
driving with lyft you can drive
in-between jobs if you're just looking
to earn extra money you're looking to
put more money in your kids college fund
if you're going back to school yourself
and you need another degree or or even
your first one like me if you're writing
the next great American novel you're
looking for inspiration drive for lyft
there are other ride-sharing apps out
there but lyft
treats their drivers right it's a
flexible way to earn extra money any
time from nearly anywhere all you need
is a car and lyft drivers can make up to
$35 an hour and get started it's easy
it's easy to get started it's just a tap
away Plus lyft drivers can earn tips
right through the app those add up fast
fast tips it all adds up driving with
lyft is super flexible allows you to
keep a hundred percent of your tips and
is always there when you need the extra
cash and right now lyft has a special
offer for our listeners you'll you'll
get a $500 new driver bonus after you
complete 100 rides within the next 30
days that's easy
go to lift calm / theö th EO today so
you can start making extra money and get
your $500 new driver bonus that's ly
ft.com / theö th do lyft calm / co
limited time only restrictions apply now
back to the episode with guest Ross
Matthews auditioning to be a slave owner
alright gimme gimme we're getting close
here you know what you what you google
search to get this line
it's all on me I want to know what the
way you put in my I put in best
slave-owner movie the part was it was
already some things that were purple
okay this is my this is my line reading
my audition okay for the color purple -
okay purple er [ __ ] just got purple do
that one right there take up the last
word you have to be a real slave owner
now mr. Matthew and I'll be the slave my
name is Lai LexA names lilac Lolich you
want to survive you do a say as little
as possible
tell no one who you really are tell no
one that you can read a right unless you
won't be dead just look up my Frieza
do you want a little more dramatic yeah
ready yes what's your name again
names lilac sir do you wanna say that
I'm doing say as little as possible
tell no one who you really are tell no
one that you can read a rock unless he
won't be dead yeah yeah good channel I
mean that's like a little part mr. Wow I
would've loved to have seen actually uh
I think that would be great if you were
in a movie where you played like a like
kind of like the gay captain of the
Underground Railroad it's so dark in
here first-class seat sir which way to
the food car quiet
I love her.she talkative but I love her
you gotta change that last name anybody
has a tub in their last name a true
American Hero
all right yes okay I've got it I'm gonna
go one question I'm gonna change with
guest Jerry O'Connell talking scientist
for those who don't know I did a spoof
of Tom Cruise's interview for
Scientology did an interview for
Scientology talking about the benefits
of Scientology and stuff using
vocabulary that people didn't understand
it was a little crazy and talking about
world leaders and stuff like that and we
pranked it it's out there you can look
at it it's some fun or not it was really
fun and you know his laughs we had a
laugh and we had a lot of fun with that
and I have not run into him I saw him at
one event and I a hid I had to be at the
event I hid for as long as I could and
then when it was like time to disperse I
I literally like I was I was the first
valet that's smart so I'm just I'm sort
of avoiding and sort of like like III
don't think there'll be a confrontation
but it's just I just I don't why why
poke that boy yeah no I agree yeah I
mean it was fine there you know it was
sort of it was rude what I did you know
I mean it was just it was fun it was
rude and I know I'm gonna be followed
and I watched that documentary I'm
kidding but um you know Slayer unity is
a so I told she's a weird place just I
you know that documentary wasn't that
amazing I thought I was gonna be blown
away by it I mean I really like that was
like event television from right yeah um
and you know I'm 41 so I don't know if
Scientology is like right in my
wheelhouse like I think if you're
younger today it's not really that big
of a deal right but like for me moving
to LA and like 98 it was like you know I
had friends who went into it when didn't
do it did you ever see them again
you know where do you see them this is
uh this is gee this is a geographical
thing there is a celebrity Center in Los
Angeles on a street called Franklin yeah
which is a popular street cuz Upright
Citizens Brigade is there so I'd spend a
lot of time there there's a bar next
door to it called yeah I mean I don't
know if this is a plug that they want or
not there's a bar next door to it that's
a French named bar right
my fella I don't want to say it I don't
want to get anybody in trouble yeah bad
bad we would we would go there often
after you see be show or what have you
after an upright citizens brigade show
and oh sorry I just hit my mum I just
hit that mute button I didn't do that on
purpose late after a um after a show and
I remember being there one night and
seeing some of my friends who I knew who
what came out to LA with I didn't come
out to LA but we were also at the same
time so we were young you know and it's
funny it's like the level of bars you go
to like when you have no money when you
come out here you go to like the super
cheap bars on like Melrose like you know
snake pit or something you know places
where you can wear your dollar goes a
long way and then you make a little bit
of money and then you go to the fancier
bars and then you know so we were at La
poubelle and a group of them who I knew
in that place we're in it were there and
it was like oh hey we're all around and
there's no rules about drinking or not
in Scientology I mean those people party
you know yeah
so we're partying and then afterwards
and remember it was like hey there's an
after party why don't you come and I was
in it that's what science how that uses
to get you involved after party but the
after party was directly across the
street and the celebrity Center did you
come and I remember everyone was walking
in the gates and you're sort of
drunkenly stumbling and you're happy to
not drive anywhere and this is before
over kids so like you'd have to wait
like 20 minutes for a cab to come or
you're taking the bus at one of the
morning I can see this and everyone's
walking in the gates and so a group of
them all went in and I was with my
brother and my brother was like yo yo yo
yo and like pointed to like the sign
this is and my brother was like oh no we
can't do this and they were all walking
in and they were like come on in come on
in and we were like no we're all good
come on man you know don't be like lame
come on Willy Wonka the night is young
everybody's a scientist and like my
brother and I were like you know
stumbling down Franklin at you know how
3:30 at 2:30 in the morning like oh my
gosh like that's it that's how they get
I'll G peer pressure it's a recruiting
tactic or they were just partying you
know that's like rude of me to say you
know
so that's a recruiting tactic as how I
yes no you know anyway we're having fun
with Abby Lee Miller falling apart about
going to prison a question about what
happened or anything that but you said
you're scared to death I've to go when
does that occur if that when does that
information come I'm just trying to find
I have no idea okay but enjoy it so much
trouble for talking about this well I
just want to know how you mentally
prepare for that you said you had a
sense of humor they know there's no
sense of it is very very very serious
very serious
so they've my attorneys in Pittsburgh my
criminal defense attorneys they've hired
a specialist I believe that will prepare
me for everything
hmm does that mean physical violence or
like lesbian overtures like so
everything Wow well I don't I don't know
how one person appears themself for that
I've never been in that situation I
can't imagine I would imagine something
that would you think of every day as
something that's hanging over you so I
know you just focus on positive things
and just know in my heart of hearts if I
knew there were different ways to do
things I would have yeah do you sit I
mean knowing that drama drive shows
everyone knows that do you think that
the production company almost
perpetuates this is a subplot I don't
think the company the production company
perpetuates it because of the production
company again was that Swift and that on
the ball they would have another show
that went more than one season okay let
me let me say I mean you're crying it's
very emotional
I'm sweating a lot okay but it is it is
very innocent okay so not tears well a
little bit about what you're asking me
what I'm telling you I'm upset because
when I get out of here I'm gonna be on
the phone all night saying why did you
open your mouth you should have said no
comment we also want people didn't
understand that I'm human I went through
a lot my mother died on TV in front of
everyone my dog died on TV in front of
everyone they
me to pick her back up and put her in
the stroller a dog stroller and push her
again two weeks later after she was deaf
what yes so I mean I've been through
hell you have it well then let me ask
and there's been good things there's
been wonderful things I've been to
Europe and I've gone to London and I've
got cool people and Patrick and and I've
I've done amazing things I've her
co-host of the view yeah and I've been
judged on Dancing with the Stars and all
of those are one time because I can't be
on another hour because of my contract
so I've done all these amazing things
and when I go around the world and I
teach a master class I might have 200
300 400 kids in one class in a big hotel
ballroom and I say has did anyone start
dancing because of Dance Moms and I
watch these kids hands go up well it was
all worth it well let me add a sign is
your support system for you you know I
feel like we know a lot about you as
what we see on the show but when you
have these you know fears or get scared
like who do you turn to and what do you
have that's tough
I can't imagine great friends good
unfortunately they're around the country
or not here you know I have some good
friends here it used to be the moms
right oh yeah and I don't know well you
know you have many fans who are there
for you and you know you have us I was
just in Miami two weeks ago and my mom
and my dad and my dog are all in the
seat they're my dad's ashes in my dog
stew stopped for the child is in my
mother's casket in Miami in the cemetery
that's what my mom had her Studios first
was it Miami Florida so they're all
there and that's gorgeous it's beautiful
it's common Cemetery it's stunning and
that's it so that's hard to look at when
you're you know being an only child it's
wonderful
never obtained it shared it for the
world however when they're gone they're
gone that's it you know I don't husband
or children or all of that that I'm
preoccupied with now that are my family
I'm in a very similar situation I was
talking to my shrink about this ring hey
there are you writing the next great
American novel and looking for
inspiration
are you seeking alternate funding for
your new startup hey I want to do a
bakery I need money
are you planning an exotic vacation for
next summer and you need to fund it well
I'd like to tell you about a smart way
to earn extra money and get an extra
$500 bonus driving with lyft
that's right driving with lyft there are
other ride-sharing apps out there but
lyft treats their drivers right it's a
flexible way to earn extra money any
time from nearly anywhere all you need
is a car do you have a car then you can
do it lyft drivers can make up to $35 an
hour and getting started is just a tap
away
you can drive mornings nights weekends
just flip in a driver mode and start
making money
Plus lyft drivers can earn extra tips
right through the app those add up fast
and you always keep a hundred percent of
your tips you don't have to wait days or
weeks to get paid you can cash out
instantly once you've made 50 bucks
thanks to Express pay so if you get paid
you get tipped to cash out driving with
lyft is super flexible and it's always
there when you need the extra cash and
right now lyft has a special offer for
our listeners you'll get a $500 new
driver bonus after you complete 100
rides within 30 days go to LY ft.com
slash theö th EO today so you can start
making extra money and get your $500 new
driver bonus lift com /c o ly ft.com
slash th e o limited time only
restrictions apply now back to the
episode with guest Maksim Chmerkovskiy
talking about Abby Lee Miller so this is
going to go back to a dance with the
Stars question the guest judge Abby Lee
she's like a real she's a real [ __ ]
that's how I like to refer to it was she
gruff with you was she heart like was it
did you feel like it was fair to have a
judge there that couldn't even do the
things I said they were judging I I
don't know what is the purpose for every
Lee Miller's existence right he's not
even to help foster good things she's
not no good things come out of that at
all I mean you know she said something I
was I was dancing with Meryl we
eventually uh
won the season I feel like she felt
compelled to say something of some sort
of critical nature right pointed out
something on her feet which was a you
know at that time we did a contemporary
routine and their feet were not part of
my you know focus if we dance barefoot
even you know so it was a little strange
for me and when I came upstairs and
Aaron asked me like so what do you think
about the comments by Amy I was like I
really don't care about what anything
this woman has to say you know and and
so this blew up into this giant whatever
I honestly just disregard people like
this yeah I think I think she's an awful
human being you know I think she she
makes money and became famous on on just
borderline child abuse yeah you know and
you know there are there are ways you
can educate and be passe rightfully so
maybe maybe that's the way to push
someone out God knows I had a studio
since I was 16 years old I've produced
tons of champions and world champions
and you know my brother was one of my
students so I was rough I was not an
easy easy teacher you know but I was
getting the result done I was trying to
get there I was trying to win but I was
in front of the class showing it right
you know somebody like ABI who I found
out didn't even dance right I mean did
you really have to these are going
that's kind of a given when you're like
I said going to school and I'm like I
want to know chemistry was like okay
well I'll teach you I have no idea what
it is
okay with Heather McDonald talking
Chelsea Handler was it hard being
friends with Chris and Chelsea because
Chelsea didn't seem to dig Chris as much
as you do I feel that
powerful as Chelsea was and she was my
boss and everything I was not one of
those people however she was surrounded
by people like this who would dump other
people that she was not friends with or
you know all of a sudden not talk to
Kris Jenner anymore oh my god am I gonna
lose my job because Chelsea woke up this
morning and hates the Kardashians for
two years right oh my god no no I was
just like no she asked me to go she
asked all the writers to go to a
Michelle Obama dinner it was to $2,500 a
ticket and I walked right into her
office and I said I'm sorry that's a
half a year of private school for my son
and I don't I don't you know so like I
don't care to meet her right and I think
she's a fine woman but like I don't care
to meet her and she was like okay
everybody else was scared shitless they
all paid the twenty five hundred all the
other writers they all went and they
never even saw Chelsea because she was
in the $10,000 place so the twenty five
hundred people were like in the living
room and the ten thousand I don't know
they've had the kiddie table of this it
was so funny that later we did we put it
in our in and after lately episode right
and in the after lately episode I'm like
I'm not going
you know like I'm like I'm not going
it's absurd to half of your school like
so I feel like you buy them being like
that and other people being like that
they're under estimating I think Chelsea
because Chelsea was like okay like she
didn't fire me because I was friends
with them I'm just like they I go to
their house every year they give my
children gifts when my parents died Kris
Jenner was at the funeral at my mom's
you know right after it's a legitimate
friendly like I'm like I'm sorry this is
like a loyal person to me that's been
really lovely and I totally appreciate
her genius I appreciate that they got
the show and took every opportunity they
could with the show because they knew
the show wouldn't last forever I think
they're surprised how long it lasts but
in the process they built all these
other businesses they were like the
first one to make Twitter profitable for
themselves and thank God for that cuz
we've all benefited from it so it's like
that's how I think going back to like
okay then go make the Chelsea I mean how
much of a minefield was that cuz I'm I
mean I was on Chelsea I was on Chelsea
once as a guest and like I'd met Chelsea
like at the comedy
and stuff like that and she was like you
know okay at the clubs and like she
didn't even look at like the people that
were guests at him she was just a talk
on the roundtable yeah she was a total
con and I would notice that like people
were and you would just see how people
were just in fear of her on this on this
show in this environment I mean how much
of a minefield was that I was I lived in
fear hundred-percent lived in fear I
enjoyed my time there I was happy but I
mean something could happen and my heart
would be like beating and I'd be like is
this it you know and and then somehow I
just managed to keep surviving but not
like she would like scream at us or
anything like that but you you just and
the people that were right under her
really like the more the years went on
she wouldn't come to the meetings all
the time so the people right under her
were kind of like our eyes and we're
sort of the only way that she would
really hear about us is through them and
that made me more nervous
yeah hang out with her we always had a
great time and then we you know then
when you'd have a weekend with her on
the road or something it was so much fun
but you know and that wasn't her fault
if she doesn't have to know the meetings
because the show is running itself then
good you know go do Pilates or go to a
photo shoot I mean that didn't bother me
yeah but that the thing that bothered me
was a little bit of that and then since
since those people she's you know not
friends with either or working with
anymore she's doing her own thing on
Netflix would you go back and work with
Chelsea again yes and the bottom line is
do you think she's a good person you
know what I think she's a good person I
I don't agree with how she treats
relationships in her life
I think she's missing out and I think
she's missing out by dumping people like
I think that that's that's kind of a
shame because it's like I don't think
you need to like cut someone out
completely like you don't have to see
them every day but you know I think and
that's the only thing like I just that's
just not how I live my life like sure I
have a couple people I do I have a
couple people that I had to cut out like
yeah but yeah but but I think she's
really funny and when you're in her life
and you're her friend
it's Devils it's the best thing ever it
is so much fun she laughs at you it you
know and that's like what's sad it
because she makes you feel so special
yeah until until you're not like and so
that's but then when I looked around and
I'm like it's so not personal to me per
se me too
it's the way she's manipulative by the
way I've never shared this with anyone
so I don't get a lot of frickin list
[Music]